K
DAY STORES.
.
DAN: I HAVE BEEN WARNING YOU
OVER AND OVER.
NOW THE FEDS SAYING THE QUIET
PART OUT LOUD.
THEY WANT DIGITAL CURRENCY.
IT'S THE BIGGEST SURVEILLANCE
TOOL IN HUMAN HISTORY.
>> SO IT WOULD NOT ANONYMOUS
INSTRUMENT.
WE WOULD BE LOOKING TO BALANCE
PRIVACY PROTECTION WITH IDENTITY
VERIFICATION WHICH HAS TO BE
DONE IN TODAY'S TRADITIONAL
BANKING SYSTEM.
JOINING ME NOW IS CRYPTOCURRENCY
EXPERT.
YOU HAVE BEEN SOUNDS THE ALARM
ABOUT THE CENTRAL BANK DIGITAL
CURRENCIES.
THIS IS THE ULTIMATE
SURVEILLANCE TOOL, ISN'T IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ANONYMITY ISN'T THE WORST OF OUR
PROBLEMS.
THE WORST OF OUR PROBLEMS IS THE
MONEY IS PROGRAMMABLE SO IT CAN
BE PROGRAMMED TO BE SPEND IN ANY
WAY THE BANK DECIDES.
THEY ARE TALK ABOUT A CARBON
ALLOWANCE.
EACH INDIVIDUAL WILL BE GIVEN A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF CARBON THEYEE
ALLOWED TO EMIT THROUGH THE
DIGITAL CURRENCY.
IF I BUY TOO MANY PLANE TICKETS
OR TOO MUCH MEAT.
MY MONEY WHEN I GO TO FILL UP MY
CAR COULD BE DECLINED.
THEY ARE CONTROLLING WHAT WE CAN
DO WITH OUR MONEY.
THE MONEY CAN EXPIRE.
DURING TIMES OF ECONOMIC
DISTRESS THE FED LIKES TO PRINT
MONEY.
THEY COULD SAY YOU HAVE TO
SPENDS 10% OF YOUR SAVINGS IN
THE NEXT THREE MONTHS.
IF YOU DON'T SPENDS IT IN THE
NEXT THREE MONTHS THAT MONEY
WILL EXPIRE.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THE SEVERITY OF THIS.
MONEY IS THE ENERGY THAT FUELS
YOUR LIFE.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE FREEDOM OF
MONEY, YOU DON'T HAVE FREEDOM OF
ANYTHING.
THEY CAN JUST SAY, THEY CAN
PROGRAM YOUR MONEY SO YOU CAN'T
BUY A GUN.
IT'S THE MIDDLE EAST TYRANNICAL
FORM SURVEILLANCE WE'LL EVER
SEE.
WHEN THEY CONTROL THE MONEY,
THEY CONTROL THE WORLD.
DAN: I LOVE YOUR PODCAST.
I THINK YOU GET THE THREAT OF
THE DIGITAL CURRENCY.
THE BANK OF ENGLAND DECIDED TO
PRINT MORE MONEY WITH
QUANTITATIVE EASING.
>> THE MORE DEBT WE GET INTO,
THE ONLY WAY TO GET OUT OF IT IS
TO CONTINUE PRINTING MONEY.
THEY ANNOUNCED THEY WILL BE
DEREGULATING THE MARKET THAT
CAUSED THE CRASH.
THEY WILL HAVE TO BORROW MORE
MONEY.
MORE DATE,